okay four people joining this meeting
was that shapeless bun from yesterday
which is why it has the wrong date on it
this is about the design of data set and
it's quite a bit to go over by the way
this form where you're doing like the
text element things like this this is a
nice form to illustrate things in how
did you generate this did you generate
it with Turkish text Ellen traffic no
sister graphic I see because I think
that putting in text element I mean
having something that is a display form
that looks like this it's a little bit
like framed or labeled you know would be
nice so you can have a nested thing I
mean does that work actually if I if I
nest labeled stuff does that work
correctly I mean if I say labeled of
labeled list labeled
no it's okay although it'd be nice if it
if it indicated yeah I wonder if we can
make it do that it's a minor comment for
I guess an ILD meeting can you pick that
up please add it like underlined labeled
or something sure it could be nice to
have something like that um okay all
right so what should we start off with
well the first item on here is just this
data data set option path notebook so
let's try to get through that okay so
you need to sign off on this is this
syntax and semantics is central to all
the data set options so we just need to
go through these element by element and
explains the syntax and raises the
issues okay okay
by the way I hope something like this
will get into the documentation sure
yeah okay so this is some kind of global
spec and this is the spec specific to a
path is that right yeah yeah and I can
have as many things specific to pause as
I wanted right
mm-hm and the path things will clearly
be non-overlapping so they could be in
an association if we felt like it I'm
not sure well so right except there's no
key for the first element so so you
can't there's a positional syntax which
just goes down successive levels in the
data set
so this is the positional syntax right
and you can have any number of those
items that they specify the values for
successive levels and then you can have
rules which specify a values for a
specific path so I mean what we could do
is to say something like this we could
say all goes to pink green
well what you want to say is all rows
and then all columns and then all third
level things well why isn't it then one
goes to what would you want to do to go
to a pink I suppose it could be just a
level number and then these things
represent kind of the the specific
exceptions I mean I kind of like having
that possibility it's been in a sense in
a sense this is 1 comma blank blank
isn't it no it's sorry no no like no
it's it's really all comma blank blank
blank is that right does this mean
alternating pink and green on successive
on on 17 that would mean first broke
pink second row green and does it repeat
if you put another layer of braces it
does okay which is just like grid syntax
okay
okay this is the spec of compulsory what
do you mean by compulsory so can I have
a list of past specs without having
their first spec that you have the pink
green I would hope so you can well you
can you can have none in the position
where there's no nothing specified no no
I mean here what what what Jose is
asking is could I just have a list of
highlights effectively boom goes to boom
boom goes to boom it's oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah so so my question is that because
numbers can also be paths they would get
mixed with numbers as levels
I should say yeah all right okay so in
this syntax you're distinguishing a
paths back by the arrow application of
it yeah
pair this well so paths are lists on the
left-hand side would you like extracted
specs right exactly but there's also a
convenient syntax if you just say earth
naked earth goes to orange that will
color everything every key that is earth
orange so if you have multiple keys
perhaps we can keep the first spec as
lists and then have an association as
the second element if we wanted to yeah
I think it's not necessary I don't I
don't think the Association is buying or
something I retract my association with
Association but I don't understand your
comment about earth I know that's it
that'll become clear when we go okay
that's just a list of options okay okay
so oh my gosh just go buy these go
through one by one let's see am i
runnable here let's just yeah yeah
you're in the year and the prototype
version I presume it's got to be the
perfect I don't know it's it's not the
yeah it's not gonna work okay all right
fine let me let me just hold on let me
get it in the prototype build I have a
prototype build or something went wrong
with my
okay here we go all right so this will
just make everything cyan right oh
that's a bit ugly how do I get the how
do I get the key backgrounds to be cyan
use the header background option so we
talked about this there was a suggestion
that if you make the background cyan it
should also color the headers I'm
opposed to that and I think you're right
to the arguments I kind of immediately
agree with you but I mean this this is
um yeah that looks that makes it look a
lot more sensible and quite nice okay
I'm good with this but I mean do you
want me to kind of guess how I would
deal with so if I said here background
arrow light cyan comma and now I said
foe boss arrow orange oh wow
so it digs through to find every foe
boss yes an orange is it that's a little
convenient syntax okay so if I were to
do that and to say radius arrow red
um okay this is quite nice I mean that's
that's cool right and if you just want
the planet radius then you would say
list all comma radius I see because the
moon's is deeper but if I said moon's
cone radius that might not look right
no won't work because I have to say all
coma moons call radius exactly and you
can figure out what to say I have a
hover over millions and it tells you
down below oh why didn't that well have
ever over all radius nap okay
pretty nice okay on would
well I don't understand okay none none
okay that's because that's the only
thing that's that deep yeah okay okay
where did these I like these very much
it's really hot yeah okay let's do this
one here why don't we get more planets
here do we lose more planets in the
solar system
I just just to keep it compact I extract
so if I can I get back to example theta
just because I just want to see what
this looks like because I don't
understand this one yeah what is it data
set list why doesn't that autocomplete
no I think it's singular I just certain
I'm worried a little bit I'm a planet
it's planets why isn't that also
completing he should report that very
little Wow well it does normally there
must be it oh I see that's okay so that
is okay so let me understand what this
does so if I just did that it will be
green it'll make that make rose cyan and
columns green and the colors combined
okay and so that's what I need if I want
to alternate right so what you've got is
a list the first item of the list
applies to Rose and the spec says make
the Rose cyclically sign in green right
so if I were to go say here you want a
color there and then well that's in a
bug which you should record right
and now you've applied the cyclic colors
to columns
I don't stand why none why I needed none
though oh I need it on the right-hand
side it has to be a color yeah okay I
understand I understand it okay so that
digs that deep that cyan greens every
column yep so if I would go even another
level none there it would do that yep
why is I don't understand that
cyan so for each moon is dying cyan for
each planet rather so if I go here it'll
be very very gated yep and we're still
using this scroller for now until we
combine this with table view so we can
just drag this out which I would really
really like I'm saying okay nice nice I
understand those
oh wow okay cool
now if I were to give an association
here well who knows what um it won't
work how would you color the rows with
the totals in them the moon totals I
think will even get to that Karl wants
this to work and the cloud so you can
share data set so hopefully data sets in
the cloud are going to work very soon
right yes I hope so I haven't I haven't
directed my attention that way but
that's see that's my intent but wait a
minute you're you have something to do
there is that a pure cloud problem well
I'll need to test things and if there
are problems point them out of the cloud
people okay can we make sure that's
Devin can we make sure that's an active
project yes and make sure that the
because I agree that this is a horrible
problem and then it has to do with the
question whether they store in the
notebook or not right that's the biggest
issue is you get a notebook and the
thing isn't published stored there the
output you mean well the full data set
isn't published stored so the data set
data is in the notebook by default now
only for large data sets okay when it
isn't where is it
it's it's just in a cache on the kernel
okay but that's not good enough right so
that has to be set up so that you
there's an option to have it store in a
cloud object right in the standard
persistence locations who is dealing
with that somebody was p.m. in that that
thing for all the different objects that
have to have out of core storage right
yes no I mean like if I say okay let's
look at this in the most basic form here
if I say cloud publish that now I mean
this is gonna be a version mismatch but
let's see what happens here
well it's robably gonna be a best
because the cloud has the old version of
the data set software
splob lawful yeah okay okay fine but so
listen to what i'm saying about these
persistent things because this is really
important and probably more important
than lots of these other things right so
we need some consistent way that when
you publish the cloud that the thing is
correctly asking you if you want to
upload and this is a mechanism and this
needs to go in the cloud development
thing I think it wants to ask you do you
want to upload the backing data did you
get what I'm saying yeah Devin do you
understand what I'm saying
yeah yeah I think this is a question for
Matt so I can I can let them know okay
okay all right Bob on live stream is
asking can you have images or equations
and these I think you can right I mean
there's not stops you having anything
yeah although images currently get some
nailed and there's been complaints about
that my intent which is not yet
implemented there's a there is an option
to control when things get truncated and
my intent is to apply that to
thumbnailing for images so you can how
do I get some images of something what
can I get image yourself let's say an
today list
okay so you're saying if I take the hose
great and I say in dataset of that okay
it looks perfectly civilized
okay data not in notebooks store now so
that's gonna mess up right yeah so if I
publish that to the cloud and again we
probably need to talk about this in the
card meeting but we probably need an
option to cloud publish that either says
you know that says what to do with those
go what I'm saying yeah and I think the
most common thing you're going to want
to do is to store them in a separate
cloud object now what do you want to do
you want to make these clickable or
something to get full-size images right
well no there's there's a proposed
option truncation function which it
Germans when things get truncated and
shown in in shorter form but the intent
is to if you turn off truncation for an
image no I understand that but I mean
I'm saying in the default case with your
thumbnail and why not be able to click
on them and bring them up to full size
well click would drill down normally but
not on an image there's nothing to build
I would say maybe a hover okay wait a
minute
click on an image could not drill down
because there's no drill ability okay
okay you're right yeah but give you a
single image or when I think you should
just give that image pop up in place you
may make it larger where it could be a
pop-up here I think it should be a
pop-up I don't think it should mess up
the structure of the data set I think if
you just pop up there like like it would
in any our viewer but let me comment on
another thing the only place where
there's drill down is when you're in the
header area right yes yeah you're right
not the content area so we're all bets
are off in terms of the content well yes
unless it's an alighted form
and then you can click I mean it looks
like an element but you can click it and
drill down ok so the question on the
live stream here about highlighting the
maximum cell on a column for instance
and I mean when we've got functions like
highlight image shouldn't we have a
highlight dataset type thing that does
that that returns a data set that has
highlighting things set somehow I mean
that's clearly so many people are gonna
want to do right so what we're just
scenario B I mean you can you can use
options to highlight the presentation
like setting backgrounds and styles and
things then I understand that but I mean
I'm saying what is the piece of code
that says go and highlight the most
massive moon so I'm saying how good is
that piece of code I say yeah and right
now it's pretty grotesque yeah right so
that we need to fix I mean that that
relates to data set apply and all those
kinds of things but that that has to
with the formatting stuff right so can
we make a list of some of these problems
to be solved because that's one Devon
are you making that list or do I need to
make the list I'm taping out okay
advanced examples
yeah I understand that
what's this 5/6
I just extracted upon okay we did this
before and I understand that make only
Jupiter's moons okay
what's this doing the none none oh I see
that that means the top two moons are
not are not colored and then you go cyan
no that means the top two levels are not
colored so if you compare that to the
true way but I thought Jupiter moons
would drill down yeah to the Jupiter
moon section right and then the result
of that is all I don't understand
so York so you're saying you expected
just to have a cyan green right hand
side the reason it works that way is if
if it drills down first and then you
start coloring from that level then
there's no way for example in the
previous examples I showed to color the
moon's cyan green by planet you've lost
the upper level if you hold on hold on
hold on hold on I understand this so I
thought this was a a color by location
type thing right yeah so in other words
that um that here so let me just check
what I'm talking about here so if I make
this thing
Jupiter moons like I just say that whole
thing is light orange okay that did what
I expected
okay now why does it not work
say but uh like this light blue okay
what did that do
why didn't that give me alternating
light orange light blue because because
you said color the top level Rose which
are the planets the first one light
orange is that go unlikely and restrict
that to the Jupiter moons Oh God action
there's a reason for that so if you if
you scroll back up to a previous example
the next one next one up here if it
works the way you're proposing there's
no way to do this if it first pulls out
the moons and then apply a scienter them
you can't color the moon's no you can't
tell of a non moons what you're doing
there is you're coloring the non moon
areas the the the case of planets that
don't have moons you're putting coloring
in there I'm coloring the planets
alternately cyan and green and I'm
restricting that coloring to the moon's
area if at first I understand I
understand it I understand that so you
think that in order to say that I want
to apply the scienter the moon's level
you have to put two preceding nuns in
there you just just go in there I I got
it I understand what the pointers here I
understand the point I'm just thinking
about this
that's pretty obscure because when I say
Phobos arrow blah blah blah right then
I'm deep diving into the Phobos element
right yeah if I say here wherever it is
you know let's imagine I did this and
God knows what that's gonna do
okay but that's deep domed
and I don't understand the relationship
between okay so this is saying at this
address deep dive and do this right the
other one is saying not at that address
but actually do something globally but
merely restrict it to the thing dis find
by that address it's always doing that
so you said make the planets alternately
sign and green and makes Jupiter Sian
and then you said restrict that to
notice so wait a second if I'm doing up
here okay if I'm up here so it's a
question where the cookie-cutter starts
a cookie-cutter in from so to speak in
some sense yeah
if I say light orange here then what
that will do is to make the moon area
icy it'll just do that okay so the
question is only the only issue when it
makes any difference to have it's what
I'm trying to do when I'm trying to
decide what the phases of my alternation
right does it start start where you've
drilled down to or does it start at the
top that's that I think is what you're
trying to say yeah yeah that's what I'm
trying to say right so in other words
basically what you're saying is there
exists a predefined set of strikes or
whatever and you are merely you know
cutting out the part of the cookie the
cookie already has its stripes on it
then you are merely defining with the
left hand side now which part of the
cookie dough you're going to chop out so
to speak right and the reason I did it
that way around was that that's more
flexible than doing it the other way
around I agree with you I agree with you
and it will make things line up properly
right but it's only relevant so in the
documentation you can explain the the
uniform case first right the uniform
case you never have a sista to this this
issue is an issue of phase basically in
the repeating things right yeah okay
fine I think you did the right thing
but it's pretty obscure you should make
sure to explain the non non repeating
thing before you try to explain the
repeating thing the documentation so one
more Chaminda in at that point so we
this met this case sorry I just coughed
excuse me what what were you saying yes
so yes this case you have now in the
middle of the screen this Metis will go
deep and look for Metis whatever it is
yes
well if Metis was wrapped in a list
would look only at the first level right
yes so that means that there's a list
key you're kind of toasted so I think
that's the difference that we are used
to the to one thing meaning at the first
level like we say part one meaning the
first level well this is not that so
this idea of go deep and look for this I
think it's the new thing here which I
agree so you're saying the conventional
interpretation of a naked Metis would be
medicine the first level yes right
although this is useful but right so
just so I understand here if I were to
go for tar quack whatever that is um how
could they be okay but if I were to go
to pan that better be green okay no no
because the planets are colored
ultimately cyan green Saturn is sian
but I was at Jupiter just now and that
was also cyan look that's just not right
well wait a minute put it all on the
left-hand side
right so there's a problem because Toph
there's like bugs there that doesn't
seem right to me
you okay cuz talk wax should be green
yeah looks like a bug um okay okay this
questions mother is a couple of comments
that it will be good to have an example
dataset to example dataset they're both
good ideas mammals cats limpid snow
droplets will be a good nice
hierarchical dataset to have we should
generate a few other examples because we
always seem to use this planets one and
the other one is continent country city
another fine one so we could just
generate a few of makes sense for the
example data thing just so we're not
always using the exact same thing plus
we can have some cool pictures of snow
leopards at the end or whatever okay
let's see there's a suggestion here that
we could actually put an operator in the
end of the sequence where instead of do
it saying all we could actually have an
operator in the background specification
no so the left-hand side is
intentionally restricted so it it it can
only name a branch of the tree the
reason being is that if it doesn't name
just a branch if it can name parts that
are separated the code is impossible
because it doesn't know what it's
counting you had you would have to look
at the entire data set even if you're
looking if you're scrolling to just a
small portion of it in order to do the
coloring if it does an entire block it
doesn't you can do it efficiently that's
why it's restricted okay
well that seems like an implementation
issue but conceptually this seems
interesting I mean it wouldn't be max it
will be take largest because that would
be giving that subsection right in other
words just like I can say in the data
set I could pick Jupiter moon's radius
right if I should be able to just take
wherever that data set is if I say here
I think I can just say if I'm not
mistaken it's this right oh oh I have to
say take largest what do I have to do
here it'll be trooper moons all radius
no no no here we go this is where we do
it before that in the query sequence
right there we go
yeah I actually had earlier I had a
syntax that would allow you to to do
this kind of thing not with operators
but with patterns and it introduces a
big efficiency well okay but the
inefficiency is just an implementation
to see I mean we could think about this
with just an indentation it means you
have to it means even if you're
scrolling in a large data set and you're
looking at a tiny window you still have
to look through the entire data set to
figure out how to apply options but you
already know what the options are I know
what the options are but I don't know if
we can you cash there is I have I have
to count I have to count elements as
they come by to know where in the cycle
I am when I'm doing cyclic coloring I
have forget cyclic coloring I mean if if
if this is about major feature that
can't be done because of cyclic coloring
we you know we could easily we can
easily elide cyclic coloring for certain
cases there may be some cases where it
can be done efficiently this seems to me
like something quite interesting because
this would allow you you know if you
want to show the largest moon by radius
this would do that see what I'm saying
this would this would target the largest
moon by radius yeah which is pretty nice
yeah
so that would keep the background
specification the left-hand side of the
background space I really like this
really really like this I mean people
might also want to annotate the size by
a color right that's a different issue
to apply a function that shows and this
is something we're gonna have to deal
with it that shows you know colors makes
a background color based on from from
red to green or something that's already
oh it is yeah that's coming okay
exciting all right okay very way minor
comment on this okay um yeah I agree
that would be very nice have to think
about right okay
um the question on the live stream is
there a way to prevent the empty cells
from being highlighted to make these
cells beyond highlighted not currently I
mean unless you go in and explicitly
override them right
it seems relevant to think about that
let's pin that issue okay
I mean because those are pieces where I
couldn't get to them with any extracts
and tacks basically I can't can we okay
let's continue
ah people complaining about having to
re-type nun nun nun nun nun yeah well
it's kind of like a spliced sequence
thing but there isn't a good syntax for
that at this time I mean that's like
saying repeated and and cyclic things
having a symbolic syntax for repeated
elements in a list or cyclic elements in
a list I mean the truth is
you know one could imagine one could
imagine now that we've had in the world
of nothing um one could imagine
something like this auto auto expanding
to xxxxX seven times actually kind of an
interesting idea and then that would
also allow you to cyclically put things
down I kind of like that idea actually
let's discuss that discussion okay
reaction to this you know I kind of like
this does anybody know where I should be
saving this what should I be saving this
please you have a folder called data set
and there's a meeting notes folder
inside of that folder
okay save there okay um
okay Lucas on our livestream says one
problem allowing operators is this no
way to tell which element returned by
the operator corresponds to which
elements of the data set
two items
samples an operator which is the
duplicate which
yeah I understand but we're talking here
but right the the things that are
returned I think it's a different
problem is that you're not returning the
index and the dataset and there is a
certain argument that some of these
operators like a map indexed should be
able to reference something some
symbolic thing that represents your
current location in the data set so in
other words if I map through the data
set it's like if I do a map index
through the data set I will be seeing if
I'm not mistaken I mean if I if I were
to do just so I understand if I would
take this guy here 945 and I were to do
a map indexed
of a print
Oh it'll print hash too now let's just
do hash one hash two um I'm 45 let's say
pick randomly at level three okay
very weird what's the kilograms doing
there that was the second part of a
quantity object there I see so this is
so in map indexed I'm seeing these key
designations that's kind of cool
actually what I see here okay fine it
works as it should do
Wow funky funky okay right so it's just
replaced everything at level 3 by nulls
all right ok onward we go okay function
values list you just asked about oh so
in place of any option value you can
have a function that returns about yeah
but in order to be recognized a function
has to explicitly have had function
well let's see so okay well that's nice
that's cool so how about the arguments
so that's saying okay item passed and
data set thinking so this is like a map
indexed and feeding the whole data set
to this thing
there's no example of why you would want
that first of hash to okay
I just colors my groups of three hip so
this is a case where you need the entire
data set this color is the entire row
that contains the sexes that color
okay okay yeah I mean this looks pretty
good it's an interesting issue that that
term well we can't change it these days
but map and next could have taken the
whole expression has another function
argument we can't do that anymore but
okay all right convenience tonight about
this yep okay equivalent syntheses yes I
understand that's the top level why is
it all in braces why is it not all
without braces let's try it let's try
let me just understand it if I don't
brace the all sure yeah I think it's
fine I can't explain off and why it does
work should obviously we'll make sure
it's intentional yeah yeah I think it
should work I don't see why it wouldn't
work I mean so if I were to say here if
I were to rather obscurely say all all
there
I see if I if I were to say now how do I
get it to do row alternation
I'm sorry column alternation on the
right hand side put it non-serbs
so in other words you want a good like
the second level okay so is that is that
way of defining the you know the cookie
dough striping is that how grid works as
well yeah maybe that's why I've never
ever understood it okay well any not
stripes first basically that's the spec
syntax is the same as grid but the
positional syntax is different and there
if you keep going there's I
okay I mean this particular thing but
this you're saying this is the same if I
were to do this for a grid what happened
here no you you can just take the
right-hand side well this should work no
grid grid is I mean this this is much
more general than grid syntax so grid
s'en yeah I see that's that's like the
first element of the background thing
before you get to the specific location
type things presumably this could be
back ported to grid yeah another thing
to think about
okay allowed values I assume they can be
key of and so on yeah okay
okay so this is the header story
it's not really cold key background no I
think you should thing don't know I mean
it seems odd to call it a header when
it's on the left and so on I mean those
things will always be keys won't they
that's the way you get those gray things
yeah I mean it looks fine as a header
once at the top wins at the side I think
it's less clear alright let's let's put
that on the side let's leave it as
header for right now what I want to
think about that again
okay Brian on our live stream is asking
don't see how to highlight the moon
total rows and the planets data set how
are they selected do you mean 200 these
yeah Brown Coast guys yeah well there's
not really a good way to do that because
that that's a stand-in for a bunch of
items all sorts of just likes okay but
just like you have a head of background
there's an argument that you have a
Taylor background so to speak so in some
sense I mean that's a tale of some kind
I mean I'm being a little bit silly that
but I mean that is that is a definite
piece of the data set yeah because you
are gonna want that somehow I'm because
those in fact in general there should be
a way to specify what kind of thing gets
written there yes and I do have a
provision for that which may also allow
you to do what he's asking okay okay
fine
that's the hell are the columns that
would be gut but that I see yes I
understand him okay
oh my gosh all right
so there's a meeting on the 11th to talk
about this issue in general
spanner II yeah
Lucas is asking on her livestream wider
datasets not
I mean wide of associations not allow
things when they do they perfectly
happily allow part specification that
was that too is not that yeah okay okay
let us continue okay I'm sorry that
you'd say there's a meeting to discuss
bands yeah boy with me yeah I don't
think it's with you sigh no yeah
Steven you're not included but it will
be brought back up in an Elsa terrific
okay because I think that these spam
things are a good idea and I think you
should be using the spam syntax for them
alright data set
I was spec on rule right hand side grid
does not yeah I understand that
yeah I understand that that's not
working at this time hopefully it will
at some point further up I'm not sure
what Lucas is mentioning here not sure
okay
oh my gosh
okay let's damn Bhagwati
rose sign columns green I agree that's
what I expected what oh yes because it
hasn't yet gone into repeating mode yeah
we know their levels races
yeah I'm not particularly well that's
the text might be useful I think that
syntax was more important at the time
when we using this as a way to make
headers in grids so what I'm saying were
the first two rows like a might be the
first row and I'd be a header and a grid
right but that's not relevant for what
we're doing now but I think it's too
confusing to change that but the most
useful thing is cyclic color so you can
scan across yeah I agree
now I mean there's a certain argument
that we should have some named themes
here do we have to insert themes now we
probably should I mean something like a
plot theme that you know we can have a
line printer version which is
alternating you know I'm white I think
it'd be really nice to have some themes
for data set because again that would
also allow one to have the different
colors for gray and you know all that
kind of stuff and I mean basically a
theme is just a setting or a bunch of
these options right all right exception
for alignment and item size so these are
options whose values can be lists which
gives the outer third level of ambiguity
and in order to make them behave the way
you would expect it greedily tries to
interpret a list as a single value and
then defaults to interpreting them
specifying levels respects I see
otherwise otherwise are just huge mess
it's a huge mess without that exceptions
the second example there's what yeah
it's kind of where we have directive and
things and graphics is to package things
in non list ways it would be nice of
there am there was someone who may
indicate that that's an atomic element
again something we could consider but I
don't think we read it yeah okay that
seems okay so in the background option
colors blend that's really funky I mean
that's what grit does and that's what
makes the you know if you have
alternating colors and rows of columns I
don't know exactly what the right blend
is though it's just bland with no
argument other than the colors okay
there's a note according to Lucas that
says keys allowed only for associations
indices only for lists and all in most
cases what does that mean in the path
yeah you cannot use it and index we're
in an association you can't ask for
their first element of an association
that could be supported but it takes a
lot of work okay fine so that's not a
that's not a semantic design issue
that's an implementation is to you at
this time yes yeah okay
so pin it is another thing um okay
column color overrides row color first
example those colors are within a single
spec they combine but if you have
separate specs and the later ones
override here later ones I think that's
correct yeah yup
seems right to me look this blending
thing is a little odd I'm just wondering
whether the actual blend blend is I
guess that's that's what it is that
there's not a lot of choice there
item style combining and not overriding
so an item style you can specify you
know old italic font size and the way it
combines those is like things override
and unlike things combined as opposed to
colors if I were to say red green in an
item style the last one in the drill
down wins it doesn't try and blend book
it doesn't blend it only blends for
background with as opposed to lost wins
and background so you're saying
background blends but everything else
lost wins yeah okay
is that what it does for grid yeah
background doesn't okay okay so this is
my argument why background should not
color the headers so currently what gets
color depends only on its index within a
data set if color header is it breaks
that because header I'm sure I don't
disagree maybe having a separate
separate track for coloring headers
makes son okay okay and you can't make
sense of cyclic colors no you cannot
totally weird okay so you asked this and
previously our meeting was a while ago
yes if that's gone halfway around the
Sun and that's fun okay fine um what is
this coloring table what so what did I
ask how you would apply an option to the
topmost level only right so if you just
say earth yellow it colors everything in
the Earth's row
but you were asking if you only wanted
to color it is radius enough double
things I mean what about a passion mass
vertical-bar radius there no that I
disallowed that for that reason I
explained earlier which reason is it
that you can't implement it efficiently
for large data sets okay
again I would like to pin that issue
because I I claim that may be an
algorithm for doing that you can
actually you can actually specify that I
don't disallow that that there are cases
where it won't work properly okay anyway
what you're explaining here is how to
whether there could be a syntax for
saying the first level for Earth but
nothing deeper yeah don't let it seep
down to the deeper levels because
otherwise okay I suppose you maybe if
you say earth comma oh well I mean
that's potentially one way to do it but
it breaks the principles it if you use
extract then you get what's it's colored
well I mean I
imagine some weird thing with earth
comma inherited or something I don't
think inheritance right it's not quite
right but it but it's it's this thing is
earth with as much trailing indexer e as
you feel like right that's what this is
doing yeah I'm going to presume there's
no way there's no way to use part two I
mean you can't indicate that in part
right which earth with everything
trailing no only the top level elements
of Earth you can't you can't get the you
can't ask for the mass on the radius
without getting all the moons as well
what I'm saying is if it's a tree and
you're getting a subtree yeah and what
you want is think well you can use level
to get just a particular level right
that would give you just a particular
level but it would then give you the top
of the sub tree of moon I don't think
this is the most heinous thing in the
world but I I agree that doesn't it's
you it's light as you with this be nice
to have a way to do that yeah I agree
because part is very hierarchical
okay how to undo coloring at lower
levels look white isn't really
necessarily what we want right it should
be probably inherited wrong well you
could put automatic there will that work
what it's doing there which should be
what it does with inherited I think
automatic should revert I don't think
automatic should mean take what you were
already got I think that should be
inherited okay because of this case for
the background automatic background
should surely be the automatic default
for the whole well it's not obvious to
me i I think it should be the automatic
default for whatever the ought whatever
the default was for that theme right
I'll have to think about that I think
there was a reason I made it work this
way but I can't recall her why's okay
but but over writing you know it's like
the graphic designers trick have you
just you know put a little patch of
color over something that's really not
not on I think in terms of reverting to
the base color yeah
this is a mess
I agree I'm withdrawing my claim okay
good we got through that notebook that's
progress is that the thing we did yeah
what is this horror so you suggest at
one point that we should if you want to
like color items in a data set you could
wrap them with item and then that would
evaporate when it gets evaluated and
changed into data set options and I
couldn't come up with any case where
that was that was more elegant than just
specifying the option what do you mean I
mean for the option you have to cover
all kinds of drill down and you know no
no I mean look at those examples those
examples show you what you have to do
those cases I don't understand I mean
what I'm suggesting is that you say you
know table if prime Q of an item and
prank U of n here item and background
arrow if prime Q of an yellow otherwise
white right and you do that much easily
with just like in that second example no
but you can't I mean it no but but yes
I don't even know why that didn't show
the items why didn't it show the items
does item not format this item work
outside of grid well but I'm just
surprised item doesn't come in wow I
didn't know that it's kind of
interesting that might be useful for
some other purposes too Wow
maybe item is the thing we should be
using more widely okay my point is I
don't want to have to be doing some weed
whacking thing with options it's like a
key it's exactly what you specified
using item except you put it in the
option it's exactly the same no it's not
exactly the same it's not exactly the
same in this case I've got the data
annotated in some way exactly exactly
exactly if I want my my you know
particular moons of Jupiter or something
or whatever it is to be green and
background
I mean without specifying a function
yeah without specifying any stuff with
the options it's just in the data it's
just like graphics imagine if in
graphics you had to be able to say oh
this particular set of points in the
graphics which are referred to by index
numbers such and such turn them green I
I strongly think this is worthwhile and
I want to know if it's and not that one
that the thing that I had here and I
wasn't not this is implementable when do
you I mean when would you construct an
entire data set by hand so that you have
that item wrapped around particular
moons I mean you well and when you're
using it primarily for for watching
probably in other words you would take
your data set you've done all kinds of
processing and then you go and in that
data set you've I mean there are tons of
things for basically for
display for information display right
but but you would reply item
programmatically you wouldn't just go in
and wrap it around some particular yes
you would yes you would because you're
constructing a data structure that has
certain items symbolically highlighted
in some way so you're talking about
working with a raw input form of the
data set items here and there
yes that's what I'm talking about I mean
very rare case I think the things with
the question of if we have a data set
with multiple of these options and we do
operations on it like well that's a mess
I mean it's the code will eventually
have to restructure the options when it
does that but for now it's just gonna
have to strip them out okay so this is
sort of the calculus of annotation stuff
for graphs how much of the annotation do
you leave exactly
wait a minute preserve item if you
reconstitute the data set now I admit
that having item be ignored in
operations on the data set is kind of
funky right in other words you could say
that item is something which is an
ignored feature of the value in the data
set so whatever you're doing in the
values of the data set it digs inside
item to look at the value inside item
and treats that as the value of that
element of the data set so you're
talking about a different thing than the
original suggestion the original
suggestion was item gets stripped and
moved into the data set options but
you're talking about actually preserving
item in the data I am actually yes I've
changed my tune here yes so that's a
different discussion you're correct and
what I'm suggesting is something much
different actually and a better idea in
my view which is to allow items in the
data set that effect formatting but do
not expect evaluation semantics
i denies Einstein well style good
question good question well item has
things like background which which style
of something with background just shrink
wraps the thing around the fiftieth like
if I say style red or something whoops
parts about that example background red
it'll shrink wrap right whereas item you
know puffs out to its enclosing region
and I would argue that item is something
which is not you know drilled into the
value that item is ignored when you
compute things with the value because it
is merely annotation for I mean it you
know this is very similar to what we
have to deal with with graphs and by the
way it's possible that we could use the
whole annotation rules mechanism here I
think that's worth looking at okay yeah
of course that's different from the way
item behaves and grid how does item
behave in good well it doesn't it
doesn't I mean it's not ignored if you
map something over the grid I know
perhaps a mistake oh boy we've got a lot
of stuff here is this we have another
meeting tomorrow don't worry about
okay I think I think I'm too hungry here
I'm afraid it's my dinner time
my away.we you're just you're just
you're making more and more arguments
for this which I don't believe for okay
i yeah Sandra and live stream is
pointing out that the advantage of
options is that the data itself could
potentially be packed more efficiently
and that's certainly true and Lucas is
mentioning Ryan possibility to stir
multiple headers in one go yes right
you're suggesting that there is a list
of lists of the header addresses are you
seeing that suggestion
so it's suggesting that this is similar
to map at
Phyllis dedicates both analysts a list
of positions at the first level right so
that's a part that's like the multi-part
using a list for the multi-part feature
of map at but there's a that introduces
another ambiguity with the level syntax
and the spec syntax I put it pin this in
the in the list of things to look at
I don't know right now maybe that maybe
that comp look so so the suggestion here
is I should cover I should color all
anything no it should cover this mass
and radius it's just a way to oh I say
mass and radius yes yeah yeah well you
could yeah okay
you can do that currently using
alternative but I don't support that for
the reason I explained okay all right um
let's go on with this tomorrow um and
yeah I just want to say is there any
chance we're gonna get resizable no
nothing zero chance for not for 12-1
okay but in principle it is is it doable
in the same way that table view has
resize ability well certainly it's
doable I don't think it's easily doable
so so you're suggesting you would have a
resize area and it would jump to
discrete sizes exposing more columns or
rows right well let's look at what table
view does so I mean table view table
views I mean it has a view into an
infinite plane which I've done but but
off to you I mean I think what it would
do is what grid would do if you resize
the window right I mean so in other
words this is like what you get in other
words things
it's like resizing and like columns can
be wider they can have more in them and
so on so it isn't really I guess I'm
wrong with its like table view
okay so here let's low let's say thirty
thirty by the way those thumbs are
different from your thumbs I mean those
those some scroll bars are different
from your scroll bars yeah okay so in
this case it does that so what it's
doing here is it just literally slices
which I don't think is the best behavior
and for data set where we really nice is
to see it I mean okay I admit this is
non-trivial allocate the space between
the different elements see what I'm
saying are you saying you want to change
the column widths or do you want to I
think in a perfect world yes I mean just
ladies well I mean do you want to expose
more things or do you want to just make
the things that are shown bigger oh I
would like to a space okay if there are
more things to expose definitely expose
more things if everything is already
exposed I think it will be nice to be
able to give the things that are there
you know like if they had to wrap text
or multiple lines and things where had
to elide the text get more space but I
would say the number one reason to
resize this is okay so what I'm
suggesting is when you can't see
everything see when you when you make it
bigger hmm when you can see everything
start being plusher with the you know
with the area given to each item yeah
yeah well it can certainly be done that
it's not a not a trivial thing I
understand it seems desirable and and
all of these things need to work in the
cloud nicely so that we can actually get
data sets properly shared in the cloud
mm-hmm well very nice work very nice
work as usual yeah a lot of detail a lot
of good things all right so we will
continue tomorrow and crank you to
everybody on the live stream they were
very helpful comments I can even tell
you let me tell you one this is
continuing tomorrow oh look at that
we've got an hour and a half
or 30 Eastern Time tomorrow afternoon so
look forward to seeing everybody there
okay good stuff thank you okay